Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
the one piece people are teasing
Season 2 confirming that
they've finished writing all the scripts
and are just waiting to start filming
episodes.
that was the whole reason
why they had the season
two stinger at the end of the finale
with that Post-Credits scene,
they knew that
they be getting a season two,
so they deliberately tease
what they be doing
at the beginning
of the next batch of episodes.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I will do one peak Season
two bonus videos during the off season.
we've also got the Avatar
The Last Airbender Live action series
that'll be coming to Netflix next year.
I'll be doing videos for that as well too.
I've already done a trailer video
so I'll link it at the end of this.
The showrunner did explained that
they have Season two completely written.
Like all the scripts are ready to go,
but they can't start filming
it till after the strike.
And Netflix won't officially announce
the season two renewal
till after the strike, even though
they kind have already renewed it.
Like that's why they wrote all the Season
two scripts.
the actual season two teaser shows
Captain Smoker from the manga
looking at Luffy's wanted poster and it's
meant to directly set up their log town
which originally was part of the East
Blue saga it, even though one piece,
Season one
was meant to adapt the full East blue saga
from the manga, the showrunner claimed
that they just ran out of money.
They couldn't add log town to season one.
They wanted to do it during season one,
but literally they ran out of funds.
So that's why a lot of stuff
got moved to the beginning of season two.
So if you've read the manga
or you watch the anime,
you already have a pretty good idea
of what Season two is going to look like.
but they were just confirming
with this post-credits scene teaser
that they will begin with log town
at the rate
that they speedrun through the manga,
they'll probably get through Log Town
in episode one and probably a little bit
more than that to like Reverse Mountain
Log Town is meant to be like
the last major town in the east
blue on the way to the grand line
before Reverse Mountain.
And that's where Luthi
and the others are headed right now.
As the end of season one.
what they'll probably do is
they'll show up at Log Town right
the beginning of episode one
and just cut out a lot of the extra filler
from the anime part of the arc
The anime turns the log town
into a bunch of episodes,
giving each of the crew members
their own separate adventures
in all their stories wind up
colliding towards the end of the arc.
Mostly it's about Captain Smoker, who's
another captain in the Marines that's in
charge of log town, learning about Lupi,
the straw hats and trying to capture him
Log Town is a big location
in the one piece universe.
It was featured briefly during season one.
It was the home of Goldie Rodger,
and it's also where Luffy's grandfather
Garp executed him,
which they also showed during episode one.
They basically opened the series
with the intro from the manga
as well as the intro
to the first season of the anime.
For the most part,
some of this version of the backstory they
show was originally part of flashbacks.
The Captain Smoker doesn't
have till the Log Town arc during that
he remembers his childhood
growing up in log town, watching them
execute Goldy Rodger the other big things
Luffy's father is also a present dragon.
They don't really feature him
during the main part of season one.
the garb stuff during season
one was also a huge change from the manga.
Maybe season two will also
change the markets for a bit and tease
his father's a little bit
more than they did originally.
like I said, his name is Dragon.
He's a little bit more of a revolutionary,
but like Luffy,
he also doesn't want to have anything
to do with the Marines
in his relationship with garb.
His father is also similar to Garp,
so relationship with Luffy,
even though Luthi and his father
are on opposite sides of the law
from him, Garp still respects and loves
both of them.
the present day, he still has a pretty
positive relationship with both of them,
But they all of this understanding
between them that even though he
respects them, it doesn't make them immune
to the Marines or the law.
the other big thing
at the beginning of this arc is Boogie
and Alveda return to Log Town
trying to revenge kill Looby.
They tease their team up
at the end of season one,
so the play has some small version
of this.
During the beginning of season two.
They'll probably not going to slim down
Elvis disappearance, though,
like they did in the manga.
A lot of people wondering about that.
She winds up eating the devil fruit
and gets smooth powers basically.
So attacks aren't able to hit her.
They just roll off.
They're also called slip powers
like attacks slip off of her
the way they explain her
getting super hot in
the manga is the devil fruit
just made her look like that.
she didn't
get any kind of crazy workout montage
or anything like that on the TV show.
Netflix will just bring her back
with Devil Fruit Powers upgrade
and she'll look the exact same.
Like they're not going to change the way
she looks that much
the rest of season two will adapt.
Most of,
if not all, the are a Boston saga.
It's way longer than the East blue saga.
So we'll see about that.
Some people think that they'll split
the arc up into multiple parts,
but the way they said they plan on doing
all of the one piece or they'd like to in.
They're probably going to keep it
to like 5 to 7 seasons.
They're probably going to speed run
through the entire saga in season two.
that means cutting out a bunch of stuff.
But they did that during season one,
so don't be surprised
when they cut out stuff from season two.
What they might do is Log Town in Reverse
Mountain.
During the events of episode one, Reverse
Mountain was the thing that they teased
with the ending of Enemies Map.
In the world of one piece.
The grand line is this large belt of ocean
that travels across the world.
It intersects with the red line,
which runs in the opposite direction.
Also around the world,
The red line is the reason
why people can't just sail from one ocean
to the other.
Within the world of one piece.
The red line is basically like this
giant mountain range that there's this
natural barrier between oceans It's
too high for normal people to climb in.
It extends so far below the ocean
that most people can't just go under it.
they're couple exceptions to this.
Like there are some races
that live on top of the red line.
Some races have amphibious ships
that can climb and some races
like the fish, people like Orleans.
People live underneath it
because they can live underwater.
everybody has to go up
reverse mountain to get across it.
even though it sounds super weird,
like they kind of tease this
at the end of season one, like,
I don't get it.
Like, this doesn't make sense.
Why would the river go up the mountain?
that is a thing in the world of one piece.
Just the way the currents,
the temperatures
work, the rivers run up the mountain.
So you literally have to sail over
a mountain to get to the grand line,
what they might do after that is episode
two might be some of whiskey peak,
maybe a little bit from a little garden.
They also probably wind up meeting V.V.
during lockdown like the manga
she's the princess of the horrible Easter
Kingdom, which is the ending of this saga,
which they'll probably use
for the season two finale.
So, like, she's an important character
that becomes part of the crew.
They meet at the beginning of season two,
probably.
she's also a double agent inside
Baroque works, which become much bigger
as an organization during season two.
They kind of tease them
at the beginning of season one,
I think just to set them up
as a bigger thing during season two,
they originally tried to recruit Zorro.
and because in the manga
at the very end of this arc,
they wind up meeting
Nico Robin, who's a really high ranking
member inside Baroque works.
They might do that on the Netflix series
early on,
but he doesn't really become
a full member of the crew until the very
end of the Arabasta saga, watch.
They could always wind up
saving until season three.
while this arc continues,
Captain Smoker continues
to try and track Luffy and the others.
but when they get to little garden
the naming is kind of a misnomer
and there are a bunch of giants
that live there.
It's also a bit of a Jurassic Park
kind of situation with dinosaurs
living on the island. It's
kind of stuck in prehistoric times.
We'll see if they go full Jurassic Park
for the Netflix series.
it sounds like it'd be kind of expensive
to do all that CGI.
So we'll see how they get around
that problem.
there's also the giant whale
on the other side of Reverse Mountain.
I don't know if they're going to do that
or they'll just have some references
or Easter eggs for it.
depends on how fast
they want to speed run.
This whole part of the manga.
They might end a little garden
and start from Island, Ark.
During episode three.
Dream Island
is meant to be stuck in perpetual winter,
so it's like a winter island.
They're mostly famous for having amazing
doctors.
Luthi in the straw hats,
also getting the help of Tony
Tony Chopper,
who becomes the ship's doctor.
A lot of people wondering if they're going
to do Chopper from the manga.
they might cut it out entirely.
They'd have to do them
with some kind of weird special effect.
Like it just be weird in general
to see them try and adapt the character.
So we'll see how they figure that out
they might end the Drum Island
arc during episode four.
Like there might be a multi-episode arc
Luthi
winding up, having to battle with a pole.
His family used to rule that island
and he's
returned to try and take control again
so they have to defeat him then in episode
five they might start to cross crossover
with the Arabasta kingdom arc.
but for the most part, at least, episodes
six through eight will probably be all
Arabasta arc during that
they have to travel with Vivi to the Arabasta
kingdom which is a desert
trying to make it to Alabarna
to prevent a big war
from breaking out the city.
Kind of reminds me of Ba Sing Se from
the Avatar The Last Airbender series one.
These came before Avatar,
so Mike and Bryan might have been inspired
a little bit by one piece
when they were creating Ba Sing Se
the whole war plot involves baroque works
who are behind everything Luffy
The straw hats have to stop them.
Vivi becomes part of the straw hats
during this arc and working with them.
But then she went up
staying in her kingdom after they finish
the main
villain of this last arc is crocodile.
so they will do the same thing
they did with all along
and turn him into a much bigger villain
during this last part of the arc
like they did in season one with him.
when the season picks up.
He's been the leader of Baroque works,
orchestrating everything.
This giant war in the Arabasta kingdom.
He's also one of the seven warlords.
Like me, Hawks
was meant to be extremely powerful.
he created Baroque works
as a way to build his power base.
Instead of like a traditional pirate crew
or a traditional pirate army.
his big thing,
though, is utter secrecy, like he's
a little fingered Game of Thrones
type of situation,
like he tries to orchestrate pull strings
from behind the scenes without letting
anybody know that he's behind everything
Baroque works is an
organization is fairly stealth,
but even within Baroque works, most people
that work for them don't know who he is
and have never met him because he goes
by a bunch of different aliases
They'll probably end season two with him
being like the big final boss Luffy
in the straw hats
have to defeat with Barbie's help.
And what they might do
is during the season
two Post-Credits scene,
like the way they tie season three it.
They'll just have some kind of scene
with Nico Robin
teasing her, eventually joining the crew.
she wound up joining the team
in that very next arc, in the next saga
that they'll probably start season
three with Let me know in the comments
how you think they'll adapt
the Aria Boston saga
for season two and how do you want them
to tease season three?
Maybe, you know, early theory
they use the season three teaser
to tease the world government.
That could be like the other big thing
that they do
in the post-credits scene is tease
the world government meeting.
their whole goal is to cover
all the manga.
And at the rate the O2 is going,
the rate that the Netflix series is going,
they might have a chance.
The one piece manga is in its final arc,
but ODA hasn't been super
clear on when the manga will actually end,
like he hasn't given an actual date
He just said it is in its final arc,
which could last for a couple more years
or longer
if he decides to keep going, which
he might do, just extend the final saga.
So it is the longest
one in the entire series by far.
post all your season
two predictions in the comments
and I'll do more one pieces in two videos
when they release more information
or an official season two teaser.
But they're probably not going to do that.
At least Netflix wouldn't announce it
until after the strike is done.
click here for my one piece, Season one
Post-Credits scene video and click here
for my Avatar, The Last Airbender
Netflix Trailer Video in Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!